what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
really big news concerning toby maguire
spider-man andrew garfield spider-man
and charlie cox returning
as daredevil this has been confirmed by
kevin feige himself the other day now it
wasn't specific towards spider-man no
way home but if we take a look at
everything we know so far and connect it
we're pretty sure it's for spider-man no
way home and i'll break down everything
you need to know about what has been
said over the last couple of days about
toby maguire andrew garfield and charlie
cox returning to play matt murdock and
daredevil in the marvel cinematic
universe also i have a really really big
giveaway coming up i went into a store
and bought pretty much every single
marvel thing they had inside of it this
will be announced in a few days so be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on the announcement okay so like i said
big toby news big andrew news and big
charlie cox news and let's talk about
charlie cox first because it's pretty
straightforward and it's coming from
kevin feige himself now there's been
rumors that charlie cox was going to
return to the mcu and reprise his role
as matt murdock they've been going on
for a while now in fact the last report
that we got stated that we are going to
be seeing matt murdock four times in the
mcu that we know just to start off with
one spider-man no way home two the echo
series three the she-hulk series which
just makes a ton of sense jennifer
walters aka she-hulk is a lawyer and so
is matt murdock and they're both
superheroes and then four it's been
reported that he's going to get his own
solo project whether that's a disney
plus daredevil show or his own movie so
some pretty big reports about daredevil
aka matt murdock but the biggest thing
was that the reports are stating that
charlie cox would be returning and
reprising his role something that some
people didn't think would happen because
he already played daredevil in the
netflix series and a lot of people
thought that well the studio is not
simply going to use the same actors but
have the character pretty much be
rebooted but that gets put to rest today
as kevin feige the president of marvel
studios confirms that if matt murdock
aka daredevil does come to the mcu he
will indeed be played by charlie cox and
let's take a look at exactly what kevin
feige said in an interview with
cinemablend he was asked about daredevil
about matt murdock about charlie cox and
here is exactly what he said quote if
you were to see daredevil in upcoming
things charlie cox yes would be the
actor playing daredevil where we see
that how we see that when we see that
remains to be seen okay we'll talk about
that last part in just a bit but right
here kevin feige confirms yes if
daredevil comes it's going to be charlie
cox that is playing him insanely good
news for everybody who loved the netflix
daredevil series and i think a lot of
fans really really did enjoy charlie cox
playing matt murdock he did an amazing
job and i believe that this really is
what fans want which is a great
testament to kevin feige really knowing
characters and really knowing the fan
base now that second part where he says
where we see him when how that remains
to be seen of course kevin foggy the
president of marvel studios can't just
come out and say yep he's in spider-man
no way home you're gonna see him there
open then you're gonna see him in the
echo series open then she hulk open he's
getting his own [ __ ] that's never going
to happen i mean just think about how
hard marvel studios and sony were trying
to keep toby maguire and andrew garfield
a secret first spider-man no way home
which we're about to talk about but
they're trying so hard they're not going
to just spoil something but here's the
deal we have seen the leaked photos of
charlie cox returning as matt murdock in
spiderman no way home there was that
photo that went around of tom holland's
peter parker aunt may and happy hogan
sitting at a table with matt murdock and
it was specifically charlie cox's matt
murdock and that photo is widely
believed to be real and now with this
announcement from kevin feige stating
that yes if daredevil comes to the mcu
he will be played by charlie cox that
pretty much confirms it meaning it's
confirmed that daredevil aka matt
murdock is going to be entering the mcu
and spider-man no way home and is most
likely going to be peter parker's lawyer
and speaking of confirmations let's keep
the ball rolling and start talking about
toby maguire and andrew garfield now
there has just been so much evidence
over the past let's say year supporting
the rumors and reports that toby mcguire
and andrew garfield would be reprising
their roles as spider-man and be on
screen in the mcu with tom holland
spider-man there's been plenty of proof
over time and we'll talk a little bit
about that but let's talk about what
happened over the weekend a huge leak
got out the soundtrack for spider-man no
way home was apparently leaked online
now this was leaked by the same person
who leaked the halo soundtrack before it
came out and it ended up being 100
accurate so since that leak was accurate
we do believe that this leak is accurate
as well for the spider-man no way home
soundtrack but still take it with a
grain of salt as it might not be however
the soundtrack has pretty much been
copyrighted on any platform that it's
been posted on so that's a pretty good
indicator that it's real and i must give
you a spoiler warning for anybody trying
to avoid some spoilers for spider-man
away home we're about to talk about them
we're specifically talking about two
tracks here for the spider-man no way
home soundtrack one which i believe was
track 19 features some of toby maguire's
theme music from tobey maguire's sam
raimi spider-man universe and needless
to say this would confirm that toby is
indeed in spider-man no way home why
else would his theme play why would toby
mcguire's spider-man theme play in no
way home if he wasn't in it and you can
say the same for andrew garfield because
there is a track that has his theme on
it as well now it is blended it's mixed
with other themes but it's pretty
distinguishable if you're a big
spider-man fan you'll be able to
recognize the theme no problem at all it
is very clear that we're hearing toby
mcguire's and andrew garfield's theme in
some of these tracks which is a huge
confirmation that they'll both indeed be
in this film now obviously we're not
going to share that audio it's been
copyrighted everywhere and i'm sure some
of you have actually heard it by now and
you can comment down below telling
everybody what you heard but this
combined with pretty much everything
else that we've heard everything else
that we've seen pretty much is 100
confirmation that toby and andrew are in
the film now again we've been getting
reports about the two of them being in
the movie for over a year now and since
then we've had leaked photos leaked
audio and not to mention tom holland
actually teased them himself in some of
the promos remember when he brought his
two special friends on and it happened
to be zendaya and jacob and he said who
else would it be yeah that was him
hinting at the two other spider-man for
those of you who didn't catch on but
first let me bring in two very special
friends to help out
i mean it's only right we are your best
friends right it makes sense for us to
join this announcement of course i mean
who else would it be i mean in the
trailers they even acknowledge the other
spider-man doc ock says you're not peter
and then doctor strange asks him when
he's in the cell do you know a peter
parker spider-man in your universe and
he says yes then he points to tom allen
and says is that him doc ock says no
because toby maguire is his peter parker
and he knows that because his identity
was revealed at the end of spider-man 2.
so sony kind of knows that we know
they're not going to admit it until the
movie actually comes out which i
definitely respect and i definitely
prefer because even though we've seen a
few leaked pictures even though we know
the experience of seeing them all
together interacting swinging for the
first time on screen is still preserved
that's what we get to see in the theater
for the first time and that's what i
want to happen seeing it in the theater
for the very first time but it's also
kind of nice to know that going into the
theater i will know that they are in the
film and if they really aren't then wow
were we really really played but i have
full confidence that they are and i
think a lot of people do at this point
in time now as well especially after
these audio tracks have leaked but let
me know what you think about this
awesome news in the comments down below
charlie cox returning as daredevil which
of course we pretty much know that
that's going to happen in spider-man
knowing home and then of course toby and
andrew returning as well be sure to like
the video and subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest mcu news and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof